hey excuse me need some help no I'm good
let me take a look you know anything
about cars so what did you say you do
well that's a secret I thought is that
well because if I told you you probably
wouldn't want to see me again who said I
was gonna see you again would you well
let's take this place say it was a bank
and instead of that counter up there
that was really a tellers window and you
just walk in real calm so you walk right
up look her in the eye and you say ma'am
this is a robbery
and you show her the gun like this and
you say but we want you to get hurt cuz
I like you I like you a lot so don't go
breakin my heart okay
you're not serious excuse me I'd like to
open up an account well great what type
of account do you have in mind this kind
[Music]
this kind you said he was armed he had a
guy you saw well he was also sort of a
gentleman he was very polite he seemed
like a nice enough fella look at that is
he smile
maude states I need three robberies in
two years you think you can catch up
myself let's hope I get the chance spent
his whole life locked up except for the
times that he broke out somebody should
have told me well you find something you
love exactly where I'm supposed to be
you're never exactly where you're
supposed to be are you now whenever I
close the door I think this is the last
time I'll ever have a chance to do
whatever that thing was you know what I
do when the door closes but you're about
the window is a gamble baby love it as
much the same wherever sat down on the
water I said surely there's an easier
way to make a living and he looked at me
and I said I'm not talking about making
a living I'm just talking about living
[Music]
you
you